les patrons l'explication le corrigé de
salaire élevé de mam par habitant fait
ça depuis le début de la semaine les
agents municipaux de trappes met sous
pli les masques destinés aux habitants
afin d'anticiper le déconfinement la
ville a fait l'acquisition de trente
mille masques lavables ça permet aux
personnes de se protéger des deux c'est
déjà ce sont des masses que réutilise a
raison mais ça me paraît une démarche
normale que font d'ailleurs on certain
nombre de communes de masque en tissu
conforme aux recommandations afnor sont
distribués en mains propres aux
habitants un mode de distribution
volontairement choisi par la mairie
je pense que ce type de démarche de
porte à porte
une démarche qui permet en même temps
d'entendre un certain nombre de
remarques d'un certain nombre de
questions et les les agents municipaux
qui ont fait ce travail me rendront
compte de je veux dire des remontées si
le logement héberge plus de deux
personnes les trappistes peuvent
demander des masques supplémentaires dès
aujourd'hui sur le site de la ville